it's going to be left-hander rich hill
who is on quite the role
you know we talked about it in the open
through four starts and era
that was well over eight at 8.82
and look what he's done since got it all
the way down to 3.89
and here is mayorfield to lead it off
and that is strike three call
outside part of the play i don't know
what whit merrifield is seeing but like
i said the second
pitch the swing something seemed off and
then he takes this for seemer that's not
even borderline
i'll tell you you know ridge hill i know
it's early
but boys he's sharp early and
cutting the miss on the fastball little
flare to finish
one two three go the royals and they'll
get brad
keller for the second time this year
yeah you know one thing that could shut
them down is just good pitching
keller is going to have to execute
especially his fastball
first man will face is g-man choi man
just came off the injured list on may
15th
it looked like a swing and home plate
umpire jordan baker said it was so he
didn't need
james hoy down at third and brad keller
just like rich hill opens with a
three-pitch strikeout
there's a chopper keller is going to
handle it and underhand his santana
covering so brad with a very good first
inning does walk one but strikes out one
2-2 to ben and tindy drives it into the
gap
and left-center and that ball is going
to be
caught kieremeyer racing
into left-center chris crossing with
meadows
and kevin kirmeyer got over there to
make that grab
on the move that was absolutely an
incredible job by kevin kiermeier
getting to that ball
and yeah that deserves a hug that is an
unbelievable catch
there's joey wendell to leave things off
and he chases a change up in the dirt
cam gets up
throws onto first base to record the
strikeout first hit of the game for
either team
now keir meyer
that's bounced over the mound and
mondassey over on the right side will go
to the bag
to force out makia here's monday
leading off and a cut in the miss
fastball up out of the zone he gets the
swing
one away strikeout this is more of what
we've seen lately out of hill
he has been razor sharp
and he's overpowered 90 up and he just
couldn't get
there no it looks like these guys are
swinging at pitches that are 100
and they're being thrown in the dark
hills ready to go as soon as he gets the
ball
a good breakfast a good breakfast i'm
i'm smelling wheaties
and a cut in the mist he goes back up
with 90 and strikes out the side
five strikeouts here it is and a ground
ball back to the mount
knocked down and loose keller's not
going to be able to recover
and phillips is aboard runner goes
pitch is a ball and the throw is late
a stolen base for phillips first moving
the third
on the play is phillips and there's two
outs so there's jandy diaz
ground ball it's headed toward the
middle base head into center
phillips scores and the rays grabbed the
lead now that lead off single converted
into a run
on a two-out single by yandi diaz
carlos santana lined out to center field
in the first inning santana's got
one homer against lefties out of his
nine
hit well deep left center field
nice call hood there you go look for one
and drive it don't try to do too much
he impresses me with his one hand
takeoff home run
carlo santana ties the game 1-1
43 pitches through the first four
allowing one run on the home run six
strikeouts no walks
how about this run last five starts 26
innings two runs
he just has not given up the base runner
and strike three called solaire
turns and walks back to the dugout
strikeout
number seven i'll tell you rich hill has
been very very good again tonight
two-two pitch swingle to miss strike
three and hill pumps his fist
he has struck out eight fastball takes
care of taylor
for the second time tonight back-to-back
singles to the right side
by a couple of right-handed batters to
start this sixth inning carlos santana
he'll stand in with first and second
nobody down
[Music]
swinging into miss and after all of that
he gets santana got him with a breaker
so nine strikeouts and no walks
wow salvia struck out twice both times
swinging tonight and the o2 to perez and
a curveball is pulled down the left
field line that's a base hit
gallagher coming around third base
here's the throw home it's cut off and
the royals take
a two to one lead two runners in scoring
position
for ben and tendy he delivers on two and
two
swinging a miss he struck him out it's
another big pitch for ridge hill
fanning ben and tendy and keeping
runners at second and third
strikeout number 10 for ridge hill
tonight
kelvin gutierrez
and he is caught looking on the inside
corner
iran scores who got to the bottom of the
6-2-1 kansas city
two up and two down and two ground ball
outs
for brad keller runway first is wendell
who has three steals
now the one-two slider called strike
three
got him looking seventh strikeout for
brad keller
who's having a very good night with lucy
struck out and
doubled and there's a wave and miss he
it's monday dropped down a bit right
there
strikeout number 13. he's just playing
backyard ball
and as well as he's pitched he's
actually trailing right now
there's a one hopper and a nice pick by
walls throws second got it
walls the rookie shortstop comes up with
a nice play right there
on the one hopper so it's two gone in
the eighth inning so a hit by pitch on
the o2
remotely get out of the way now here's
ben
and tendy sending one deep into left
center
and caremeyer is there to catch it
hereby with a leaping grab smith ball
headed for the wall and keermeyer got
back there to make the leaping catch
second chance he's made tonight
that has everybody on their feet
one on one out here in the ninth
francisco
mejia will be the hitter and that is
grounded out to monday
to gutierrez and over to santana
and he did ding ding ding ding get him
in the lane
believe it and the royals have done it
they end
the tampa bay rays 11 game
win streak the royals have won five of
their last
six the royals with a 2-1 victory